schön dass sie dabei sind meine damen
und herren wo immer sie uns heute gucken
faules brückentags gesinde ja
es arbeitet ja keiner mehr in
deutschland keiner arbeitet mehr außer
olaf scholz der sammelt unermüdlich
prämienmeilen diese woche auf
staatsbesuch war überall im niger im
senegal in südafrika in der schweiz kurz
gesagt er war überall außer in kirsch ja
ja ja gut das ist inzwischen seine trotz
geschichte bei ebene schwieriges alter
wenn wir jetzt alle sagen würden olaf du
darfst in keinem fall nach kiew fliegt
er morgen garantiert hinweis sprechen
wobei klar die afrikareise natürlich
wichtig war den kontinent haben wir viel
zu lange vernachlässigt hier scholz im
niger beim fröhlichen hymnen raten
[Musik]
ist es vorbei
mein gott sie hörten eine akustische
zusammenfassung der ersten 171 tage
ampel meine damen und herren
ja gut vielleicht auf einer besser dass
er erst mal nicht nach dir fährt herr
scholz die sind ja gerade nicht so
richtig gut auf ihn zu sprechen denn in
sachen schwere waffen arbeitet seine
regierung inzwischen mit der wievielten
ausrede ich habe aufgehört mitzuzählen
es ist nur noch peinlich
der kanzler spielt auf zeit zeit die die
ukraine gar nicht mehr hat und die
abstimmung über das 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für unsere bundeswehr ist
letzten freitag auch geplatzt also über
100 milliarden neue schulden für die es
übrigens noch nicht mal einen
tilgungsplan gibt ja ja gut dass
das liegt wohl am zoff mit der union
aber auch am widerstand aus der spd hört
man ist schade schade und ich dachte
jetzt kommt die große wie heißt das noch
was wir gerade erleben kommen wir
erleben eine zeitenwende zeitenwende
zeitenwende zeitenwende zeitenwende
gezeigten wendezeiten der zeit dass wir
infolge der zeitenwende dieser
zeitenwende zeitenwende history addon
turning point zeitenwende zeitenwende ja
wir erleben eine zeitenwende
nein
eigentlich nicht die letzte echte
zeitenwende war neulich als wenn die uhr
sommerzeit gestellt haben für das
bundeswehr sondervermögen müsste sein
kanzleramt einen sogenannten finanzplan
erstellen wo zumindest ungefähr
drinsteht was man wofür ausgeben möchte
liegt nicht vor olaf möchte stattdessen
einen blanko scheck vom parlament für
sachen eher vage sagen wir mal es
weiß ja auch bis heute niemand wie sie
auf die zahl 100 überhaupt gekommen sind
oder wie wir es geschafft haben mit dem
zweitgrößten der etat der eu eine der
kaputten armeen der welt zu haben
50 milliarden jedes jahr da müsste doch
mehr drin sein als dass hier die stets
seien generell um die ehre flugabwehr
das ganze einfach es gibt keine heeres
flugabwehr
achso
vorteil wir sparen tierisch munition und
deshalb wenig nicht zufällig laut
generalinspekteur der bundeswehr
bräuchte man alleine 20 milliarden euro
um die munitionslager wieder aufzufüllen
zack 1 55 vom sondervermögen schon weg
die bundeswehr wirklich in erster linie
wie es immer heißt kaputtgespart die
wirtschaft gemeldet es werden falsche
prioritäten gesetzt beispiel unsere
elite kampfschwimmer in eckernförde das
kein witz haben seit zehn jahren keine
eigene schwimmhalle
wo trainieren die im kinderbecken vom
spaßbad oder was
[Applaus]
ausgerechnet den fallschirmjägern fehlen
helme
gut besser als fallschirm aber trotzdem
von unserem großgeräte problemchen mal
ganz zu schweigen und das produziert die
enttäuschungen einer ein mensch der
panzer fahren möchte oder da seinen
dienst leisten möchte und findet kein
panzer vor oder ein hubschrauberpilot
kein hubschrauber vorfindet das ist
natürlich kontraproduktiv
ich habe völlig richtig panzer fahren
ohne panzer ist kontraproduktiv
vorschlag meinerseits bevor wir die
nächsten 100 milliarden verballern
versuchen wir doch erst mal die 50
klüger auszugeben vielleicht könnte sich
die verteidigungsministerien da mal
beraten lassen von guido maria
kretschmer oder so das ist was ich als
eine idee
eines eine studie der uni hamburg sagt
die wahren gründe für waffensysteme die
viel später kommen und immer teurer
werden die ligen tiefer die bundeswehr
bestellt zum beispiel gerne den
deutschen gold standard stadt verfügbare
günstigere waffen aus anderen ländern
während man dann jahrelang auf den
goldstandard wartet haben sich die
anforderungen schon wieder geändert ja
wo es wird noch teurer + natürlich die
sache mit dem lobby einfluss ja ja
natürlich politiker
politiker bevorzugen den waffen
hersteller in ihrer region haben möchte
sich gar nicht vorstellen wie die
berliner waffenlobby steil geht seit das
sondervermögen im raum steht da sitzt
für die spd im verteidigungsausschuss
ein traumjob bis zu diesem moment der
bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses
sondervermögen einmalig mit 100
milliarden euro ausstatten
traum liegend 100 milliarden steuergeld
suchen einen neuen besitzer in einer
stadt voller waffen lobbyisten wenn sie
frisches geld wittern dann gnade gott
[Musik]
ja ich entscheide das ja nicht alleine
was wir kaufen
[Musik]
es gibt kein entkommen denn sie sind
über alle
[Applaus]
gott sei dank
aber irgendwie einen sud du willst es
doch auch
[Musik]
besonder vermögen die nacht der lebenden
lobbyisten
gruselig
echo sie mich ja mal sehen ob das noch
was wird mit dem sondervermögen und ob
christine lambrecht da noch
verteidigungsministerin ist krieg in
europa und ausgerechnet jetzt haben wir
auf dem posten der frau die
offensichtlich keinen bock drauf hat er
beim bundes man entsetzt
entsetzt weil sie zum beispiel
weihnachten lieber in ischgl war als bei
der truppe und tatsächlich sucht die
lamprecht sicher längst selber was neues
sie hat gerade erst versucht
innenministerin nancy faeser das ressort
zu cloud wirklich die nennt sie sagt
christine würde ja eh bald als
spitzenkandidatin in hessen antreten wie
sie das findet
ich ärgere mich natürlich in der regel
wie über kollegen
ja noch recht politik die fressen
die hatten neulich gab es einen großen
spiegel artikel über die
verteidigungsministerin und der war
wirklich verheerend da stand dass sie
sich zu wenig einarbeitet nachmittags
gern früh feiern macht und am liebsten
jacobs instantkaffee 2 1 1 trinkt was
ich von allem am schönsten fand muss ich
sagen wir schalten wir live ins
verteidigungsministerium zu ihrem
referenten hauptmann albrecht umbau der
hauptmann stimmt das dass ihre chefin
noch immer nicht die dienstgrade kennt
dazu schulen die sie doch gerade der
kamerad davon zeigt ihr welche
schulterklappe was bedeutet leider
bleibt oft wenig hängen obwohl wir schon
mit eselsbrücken arbeiten beim general
zum beispiel mit dem putzmittel oder
beim major mit dem gewürz mayo an
ich möchte sie es nicht mit dem herzen
bei der sache aber hey man kann es auch
positiv sehen wir hatten noch nie eine
ministerin mit so einer fantastischen
work life balance
außer dem archiv von der leyen war auch
nicht vom fach gut die hat sich dann
rein gefuchst und die truppe hat sie
abgöttisch geliebt wie diese szene
beweist antreten zum guten tag sagen
guten tag soldatinnen und soldaten
wirklich ganz melancholisch aber kommen
wir müssen jetzt irgendwie mit der lampe
recht klar kommen dreifach quote frau
linke spd flügel und hessen machst du
nichts was ein bisschen nervt ihr
21-jähriger sohn hängt ja auch ständig
rum wir mussten ihm davon so eine
spielecke einrichten
aber stimmt das eigentlich dass sich der
britische verteidigungsminister
offiziell bei der bundesregierung
beschwert hat weil er nicht meine
telefon termin kriegt bei frau lamprecht
also das wüsste ich aber
mein gott sie spricht kein englisch und
ich wünschte das wäre ein witz
man ändert die frau jetzt nicht mehr
übrigens auch nicht ihre latente
putzigkeit sie persönlich die die immer
wieder auch in die situation kommen sich
dann rechtfertigen zu müssen schön sie
sich missverstanden oder prallt das auch
etwas ab ich muss mich überhaupt nicht
rechtfertigen
warum hab ich ihn die roten nicht
verweigert damals
sekunde ich bekomme reinwachsen
ach du scheiße unser letztes u boot hat
den grünen fresser frau ministerin wir
müssen sofort eine pressekonferenz bevor
die bild zeitung
natürlich der brückentag sie klingt
jetzt nach mallorca war ja klar
man erwarte
albrecht und vielen dank
kaufmann
ein recht können die zuschauer
wissen sie was richtig doof ist wenn
sich ein problem für das man gerade echt
keinen nerv hat in den vordergrund
drängen jetzt ist doch krieg in der
ukraine wer will denn da noch was vom
klima hören können sich die krise nicht
mehr untereinander absprechen scheinbar
nicht
zu viel verlangt rekordhitze in indien
ständig starkregen tornados in paderborn
experten befürchten wir könnten 1,5 grad
erderwärmung möglicherweise schon in
vier jahren erreichen passt mir
terminlich überhaupt nicht muss ich
sagen aber was bedeutet putins krieg für
unsere energiewende einerseits erlebt
die kohle leider ein comeback auf der
welt flüssiggas ist der neue heiße
scheiß und die eu will zusätzliche co2
rechte versteigern quasi ein
brandbeschleuniger für die klimakrise
andererseits geht es vielleicht
schneller beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
das spürt man plötzlich da ist ein ganz
neuer zug drin eine eine fast schon
brutale dynamik der plan gigantisch auch
beim tempo tempo geschwindigkeit und
größenordnung werden von unvorstellbarer
umfang sein
wenn wir weitermachen in dem
unvorstellbaren
tempo
dann kann sich putin aber warm anziehen
freunde ja scholz spricht hier vom
nordseewind packt den wir mit belgien
niederländern und vor allem denen
angehen dänemark will schon
2028 seinen kompletten strom aus
offshore wind gewinnen dafür brauchen
sie jetzt eine energie insel mit
hunderten windrädern und zehn gigawatt
leistung ist der wahnsinn tatsächlich
sind die dänen absolut führend in sachen
windtechnologie bei uns macht demnächst
mit der firma nordex in rostock der
letzte laden dich dennoch selber große
rotorblätter für windräder herstellen
kann frage warum geht das mit dem wind
in deutschland so langsam voran warum
warum haben wir in den letzten jahren
immer weniger windkraftanlagen gebaut
kann mir dass meine erklären wind ist
nicht das einzige wind ist aus der ferne
wahnsinnig sympathisch aus der nähe
manchmal ziemlich erdrückend das ist die
eigentliche problem stellung die man
halt hat vor ort
der markus findet wind erdrückend vor
allem diesen durchzug zwischen den ohren
ja
die bayern sein bundesland die legen mit
gerade einmal 0,02 windrädern pro
quadratkilometer ganz hinten im ranking
nicht zuletzt dank 10h abstandsregel
mittlerweile dauert es in deutschland im
schnitt sieben jahre eine
windkraftanlage zu bauen das gibt's doch
gar nicht sieben jahre robert habeck
arbeitet übrigens an einem gesetzentwurf
der die abstandsregeln in den ländern
aushebeln würde allerdings mit dem
zusatz dass die bestehenden
mindestabstände vorerst fort gelten
könnten und wie lange vorerst dauert
steht da vorerst nicht drin
auch ein grüner wirtschaftsminister muss
kompromisse machen übrigens auch
zwischen flüssiggasterminals und
artenschutz ich liebe schweiz wahrlich
kommt vor der küste ich habe wir haben
der fischerei große anstrengungen
unternommen das verenden in den netzen
zu beenden also ich bin der größte
schweiz waren in der bundesregierung
vermutlich schweinswal schweiz wahl
ich meine klar jeder mag schweinswale
geräten im schönen riesling warum ist
tatsächlich ist das jetzt gerade nicht
die zeit für hyper moral wir müssen weg
von putin stoff und ich sag mal wer beim
emir von katar um allen siegers bettelt
der kann auch mal nord und ostsee
umgraben man nennt es realpolitik liebe
kinder hier neuer grünen spot
wir von den grünen sind prinzipiell
immer noch für artenschutz aber gibt es
wirklich für alle arten was zum beispiel
haben mögen je für uns getan nervige
arschlöcher und robben neben einem die
schönsten plätze auf der sandbank weg
wie so fette engländer but what the [ __ ]
scheißen den ganzen handvoll aber vor
allem schweinswale was bitte wollte
eigentlich sein schwein oder wahl
entscheide dich mal dumme sau kurz
gesagt echt sorry aber wir brauchen die
nordsee jetzt leider für strom eure
grünen den artenschutz ist keine
einbahnstraße
es ist nicht schön aber in dieser welt
lage gibt es eben keine schönen lösungen
mehr trotzdem müssen wir ja ukraine
krise und klimaschutz irgendwie parallel
bewältigen sprich steuern senken also
den fossilen brennstoff benzin
subventionieren macht daher wenig sinn
so nett dass bestimmt gemeint ist von
tank redman
regen rabatt seagal ist egal wie viel
mehr energie sparen würde helfen gibt es
da vielleicht noch ideen aus der fdp
wenn man sich die die zahl der fotos von
essen anschaut weltweit dann kommt man
auf einen enormen energieverbrauch und
muss sich die frage stellen ist das
wirklich notwendig genau
genau und bevor sie jetzt lachen oder
sich noch mal die ganzen essens fotos
angucken die volker wissing in den
letzten jahren selber gepostet hat in
der sache hat der mann völlig recht das
internet verbraucht tierisch energie und
niemand braucht food vorn im netz ich
behaupte sogar wir können fast alles was
auf social media passiert einfach aus
dem offenen fenster raus erledigen guck
mal ich hab mir kartoffelsalat mit
würstchen gemacht interessant oder auch
die ganze internet hetze das gebirge
geht super durchs fenster den
menschengemachten klimawandel ybbs kann
ich du [ __ ]
ein
ausrufezeichen
steht
weniger posten weniger heizen langsamer
fahren anders wird es kaum gehen
fürchtet der niedergang der deutschen
windkraftindustrie ist jedenfalls
besonders bedrückend weil wir dabei
exakt die fehler wiederholen die wir
schon bei der solarenergie gemacht haben
deutschland war ja mal das mekka der
photovoltaik und dann nicht mehr es
wirklich ein historisches versagen
herzlich willkommen zu
[Musik]
und die show history mit valerie niehaus
liebe zuschauer es ist eines der größten
rätsel der deutschen geschichte wie
haben es unsere vorfahren geschafft
damals in grauer vorzeit also zwischen
2010 und 2020 die deutsche
solarindustrie komplett verschwinden zu
lassen wer ist da vor allem schuld und
ab wann genau war die luft raus
[Applaus]
peter altmaier von beruf windmaschine
und ex-umweltminister einer der vielen
väter der vernichtung unserer solar
branche es ist so schade ist es so
schade bis 2010 fand fast die hälfte des
weltweiten solarbooms in deutschland
statt und schien quasi die sonne aus dem
arsch direkt reinen stromnetz
und das konnte so natürlich nicht
weitergehen fand die kohle und gas lobby
deswegen hat man die solar
einspeisevergütung die 2007 noch bei
fast 50 cent pro kilowattstunde lag bis
2020 auf unter 9 cent runter gedengelt
genial so ist der ausbau in wenigen
jahren um 80 prozent eingebrochen
peter altmaier hat sogar mal laut
darüber nachgedacht die vergütung
rückwirkend zu kürzen um auch noch die
letzten investoren
[Gelächter]
die damalige bundesregierung hat halt
gefremdelt mit den regenerativen auch
bei der windenergie wie diese
deprimierenden aufnahmen unterstreicht
ja aber im moment bevor wir jetzt nur
auf schwarz-gelb rumhacken auch heute
kämen absurde vorgaben und bürokratie
den ausbau wer zb mit seinem sonnenstrom
auch den nachbarn versorgen will wird
zum stromanbieter und im prinzip vom
staat behandelt wie eon oder vattenfall
warum weiß man nicht er ist auch egal
nach vorne schauen wir müssen jetzt raus
aus der abhängigkeit von putins gas und
da helfen eben nur die erneuerbaren ganz
viele solarmodule zum beispiel aber die
bauen wir ja nicht mehr ja wir nicht
aber andere bei erdgas sind wir zu 55
prozent von russland abhängig bei
solarzellen die nun erdgas ersetzen
sondern liefert china
95 prozent
statt russland ist dann ausgerechnet
hier unser neuer show kd die nächste
abhängigkeit oder was suboptimal
zugegeben zumal der solarzellen rohstoff
polysilizium oft durch uiguren
zwangsarbeit produziert wird aber
irgendwas ist halt wie blöd waren wir
bei wind und sonne sind
zusammengerechnet über
hunderttausende arbeitsplätze in
deutschland vernichtet worden durch
aktive politik bei der braunkohle
scheißen wir uns einbringen der handvoll
kumpel also das kann man überhaupt nicht
vergleichen
verwenden bergmanns chor singt glück auf
der steiger kommt da geht einem das herz
auf das funktioniert nicht mit glück auf
der photovoltaik anlagen mechatroniker
kommt
sie können es ja gerne mal versucht
absolut kein problem
ich ihnen so runter
[Musik]
auf mit
der photovoltaikanlage mechatronik corp
und er hat sein china solar module dabei
und her hat sein
das solarmodul dabei vom kunden
[Musik]
von u
gebaut
[Musik]
ja ich konnte
und die stelle die story
[Musik]
wahnsinnig auf
ja
laut ifo-institut gibt es heute in
europa keine nennenswerten produzenten
von solarmodulen mehr läuft so ganz was
anderes putins krieg in der ukraine
findet nicht nur auf dem realen
schlachtfeld stadt sondern natürlich
auch in den sozialen netzwerken experten
sprechen schon vom ersten tik tok krieg
der welt
und wenn sie sich jetzt fragen tik tok
ist dass sich diese app auf der dover
teenies ihre lippen synchron zu popsongs
bewegen kann ich nur sagen
2017 hat angerufen und möchte seine
vorurteile zurück
hat iqdoq kann heute so viel mehr plumpe
propaganda zum beispiel
die ukrainische regierung ist eine
marionette der usa um russland zu
stürzen erst ist russland dran als
nächstes wir in china
meine güte und yankow hat die trennung
von bibi aber überhaupt nicht gut
vertragen
haben sie zu hause den witz verstanden
nein ich auch nicht da hatten wir unsere
heute steckt redaktion aufgeschrieben
dabei habe ich den habe ich den richtig
vorgetragen nein ich bin voll peinlich
das wusste ich ja
tik tok chinesisches videoportal mit dem
slogan make your day sollte man dringend
umbenennen in face your day aber der war
nicht schlechter oder war auch schlecht
gut
auf tik tok laufen propagandavideos
unmittelbar nach süßen katzen oder
schmink tipps wie zum beispiel
irgendwelche idioten einfach szenen aus
einem computerspiel als luftkampf in der
ukraine verkauft warum auch immer
15 millionen deutsche nutzen tik tok der
allergrößte teil davon ist unter 25
jahre alt und obwohl man eigentlich
mindestens 13 sein muss um diese app zu
nutzen haben auch sehr viele
grundschulkinder einen account der kreml
arbeitet garantiert längst an passenden
propaganda inhalten genau zugeschnitten
auf unsere kleine sachen wie benjamin
blümchen erobert neustadt und entführt
den nazi bürgermeister oder der hund von
portixol beißt ein putin gegner in den
arsch und natürlich schauen dass
scharfschütze
werden
es ist das eigentlich so wenn ich einen
neuen tik tok account anlegen kriege ich
im schnitt schon nach 40 minuten fake
meldungen zur ukraine vorgeschlagen also
vom algorithmus selbst wenn ich
eigentlich nur harmlose stylingtipps
will dem algorithmus egal eine eine neue
analyse des desinformations situation
centers belegt das tik tok anfang mai
blockierte kremmener kanäle wie rp
online in der europäischen union gerade
wieder freigegeben hat aber woran
erkenne ich kreml propaganda zum
beispiel gibt es skripte die an
influenza innen aus russland
herausgegeben werden und dann finden ihr
mannigfaltige videos in denen in sven
starr in alle das gleiche sagen und das
was sie sagen sind ganz klar dessen
verband war es vorher geschriebene
skripte auf denen die nachrichten stehen
wer macht denn so was meine damen und
herren liebe
presse presse egal ich verstehe kein
russisch denkt man aber dann sieht man
alina lipp auf tik tok deutsch-russische
influenza rinn und hardcore putin fan
ist nicht übertrieben
sie war
angeblich bei den grünen lebt inzwischen
auf der krim und betreibt gleich mehrere
propaganda kanäle oder ist das doch
comedy
nicht die russen die bösen die russen
nehmen gerade ganz platt gesagt den
ärzten die waffen weg ja das stimmt
jetzt wirklich gar nichts außer ganz
platt gesagt
frau lipp hat unter anderem mitgeholfen
die nachricht zu verbreiten das
ukrainische flüchtlinge in euskirchen
einen jungen russen zu tode geprügelt
hätten komplette erfindung von vorne bis
hinten warum sollten flüchtlinge nach
euskirchen gehen
erwachsene müssen mit solchen fake news
irgendwie klarkommen bei kindern und
jugendlichen auf tik tok ist das schon
ein problem natürlich kann man mit jedem
medium schlimme und gute sachen machen
mutige menschen in der ukraine posten
zum beispiel bilder aus dem kriegsalltag
wieder andere nutzen tik tok schamlos um
sich an die jüngere generation
heranzuwachsen wie diese zwei
spd-abgeordneten politik kurz und knapp
donald challenge
zusätzlich zu den im februar gestorbenen
100 euro weitere 100 euro extra für
sozialhilfeempfänger innen
warum
eine sau challenge wären mal über
sozialhilfe redet mal was anderes
schamgefühl städte aus und ich bin mir
relativ sicher ein teil unserer leben
zdf kernzielgruppe ist nach den letzten
sendeminuten sehr verwirrt zurecht
deshalb hier noch mal alles wissenswerte
über tik tok nur halb für sie analog
erklärt
[Musik]
liebe senioren sie sind jetzt verwirrt
weil der korpulente moderator aus der
hitze sendung die ganze zeit über tik
tok geredet hat aber was zum henker ist
ein tick tock tock tock ist kein
leckeres pfefferminz und auch nicht die
große uhr in ihrem wohnzimmer tik tok
ist das was ihr enkelkind inständig auf
dem handy zeigt das typische tik tok
video ist und laut und absolut sinnlos
im grunde wie die zdf show mit diesen
anstrengenden italiener nur halt in 15
sekunden und dann auch noch hochkant
hoch mir wird schwindelig außerdem gibt
es ständig sogenannte challenges die
klopapier challenge die reps challenge
oder die bierkästen stellen aber vor
allem tik tok ist nur was für junge
leute unter 25
ach ja und für kai pflaume
[Musik]
wie sagt man so schön
wird's nicht guten abend
[Musik]
die haben gesagt ich soll meinen
lieblings witz erzählt es mache ich
gerne also kommen ein pferd chef base
und der papst in eine bar sagt der
barkeeper
abonnier endlich den zwei takten heute
schon kanal also geht doch